Alabama moves to ban abortion aoc
declares war on Joe Biden and Elizabeth
Horne to Claire's war on fox news i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay we are gonna get to all of the
myth-making surrounding abortion law
today we are going to get to the impact
of the Alabama law that is likely going
to be signed into law by Governor K IV
today but first in 1966 alan greenspan
famously said quote deficit spending is
simply a scheme for the confiscation of
wealth that is obviously true but the
federal deficit currently touching a
trillion dollars eve every year what are
you doing to protect your savings from
this confiscation scheme greenspan
offered one solution he said gold stands
in the way of this insidious process
could you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last day on turn
when the S&P dropped 50 percent hedge
against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability by
diversifying at least a little bit with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company i trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move that IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver which is perfect for people
who would like to protect their
hard-earned retirement savings from
future geopolitical uncertainty look
back historically when the bottom falls
out of everything else gold does tend to
safeguard savings because it has never
been more than zero Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group and get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals right now they've got this
comprehensive 16 page kit showing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
go check them out right now by texting
been to 47 47 47 again text my name Ben
to 47 47 47 that's Ben's whoo 47 47 47
okay so the big controversy of the day
obviously surrounds the passage of this
Alabama law so Alabama has now moved to
pass a law that effectively bans
abortion in the state unlike the law in
Georgia that is a heartbeat bill and
says that for the first six weeks of
pregnancy you can get an abortion
effectively on demand and then beyond
six weeks you cannot and then it
punishes abortion doctors the Alabama
law goes even further the Alabama law
goes right to the heart of the matter
and says that the unborn are human lives
it says that they have the status of
persons under Alabama law and this
challenge is directly over
wait Roe vs. Wade says no these are not
persons instead these are basically
developing some things and that means
that based on viability standards you
can kill a baby or you can't kill a baby
based on viability standards or states
can pass laws that prevent the killing
of the unborn depending on viability and
that the standard is incredibly murky
under Roe vs. Wade and then it gets even
murky or under Planned Parenthood versus
Casey which is a case from the late
1980s early 1990s has moved its way up
through the courts in which the court
basically ruled to limit Roe vs. Wade
but Wade and said that you can't pass a
law that creates an undue burden on a
woman seeking an abortion the undue
burden standard has always been quite
vague and my forecast has been that the
Supreme Court with the new Republican
appointed majority would start paring
back at Planned Parenthood versus Casey
but would not overturn roe v wade it
would leave in place the idea that a
woman has a quote unquote right to an
abortion but it would pare back at the
lengths to which that right extends I
think that is still the likeliest path
for the supreme court Alabama is
challenging it outright however they've
passed a law now that says abortion is
banned in our state and abortion doctors
can go to jail anywhere from 10 years to
99 years and life begins at conception
has a full pro-life bill now a lot of
people on the right are uncomfortable
with the pro the the full pro-life bill
many of them are uncomfortable mainly I
think because of the optics so the bill
does not have an exception for rape and
incest which makes logical sense I know
that it doesn't make a lot of emotional
sense for people they're saying well you
know a woman gets raped and now she has
the burden of carrying this child to
term you're right it is a a grave burden
on the woman that she has to do this
which is why it's an act of heroism for
any woman to carry that child to term
what that said if you believe that a
human life is a human life in the womb
the fact that a grave wrong was done to
initiate the creation of that life does
not mean that the life itself is of no
value there's a logical distinction
between the evil that was done to create
the life in the first place and the
presence of the life now that the life
is present that's why I've always been
in favor of an exception in case of
serious danger to the mother and that
would include mental health the woman is
going to go crazy and harm herself for
example if a woman is going to to be so
depressed that you become suicidal then
abortion in my view becomes an option
because now the more the mother's life
is in danger and you stake her life
against the life
of the human life in her womb Alabama I
think by the way does the right thing
from a pro-life perspective when it
comes to rape and incest concessions
with regard to rape and incest have
always been sort of a stop to public
opinion rather than a principled stand
about the value of human life they also
opened the door to the argument okay
well if you are saying that a human life
is not a human life if you don't want it
to be a human life then why wouldn't you
extend that to cases other than rape and
incest it's also worthwhile noting that
the left tends to point out arguments
about rape and incest because those are
the most emotionally resonant cases in
which people who are generally pro-life
would say well maybe an abortion should
be on the table that's why the Left
likes to pick on it the reality is that
rape and incest represent significantly
less than 1% of all abortions in the
United States and so I've always said
that if you are not looking to just
challenge roe v wade outright if what
you're looking to do is create a
consensus around abortion what you say
to folks on the left is listen we'll
leave rape and incest alone for the
moment and let's agree on the stuff that
we can agree on because what the Left
likes to do with the rape and incest
exceptions is they like to say okay well
you know since everyone agrees that rape
and incest exceptions should exist and
therefore all abortions should be legal
the logic should really be the other way
around
okay so let's even say that rape and
incest exceptions should exist does that
mean that you're against all the other
abortions or are you just using the
outlier case in order to justify
abortion in the vast majority of cases
in any case the the hard pro-life
perspective the the obvious pro-life
perspective here when I say hard I don't
mean vicious or brutal hard I just mean
like the bare bones pro-life perspective
says a human life in the womb is worth
protecting no matter how that human life
was initiated in any case according to
the New York Times the Alabama Senate
approved a measure on Tuesday that would
outlaw almost all abortions in the state
setting up a direct challenge to Roe
versus Wade the case that recognized a
woman's constitutional right to end a
pregnancy
now even the euphemistic way that the
New York Times talks about this stuff is
pretty amazing the right to end a
pregnancy that that's not ending a
pregnancy guys right that is an
editorial choice that you are making is
a right to an abortion at the very least
a right to snuff out a human life in the
womb at the very most right to end a
pregnancy okay if you have a miscarriage
that is your right to end a pregnancy
right there also you have a right to
prevent a pregnancy by not getting
pregnant
the first place you can tell the way the
New York Times likes to slanted stories
from the very outset the legislation
bans abortions at every stage of
pregnancy and criminalizes the procedure
for doctors right not for women
so all the lies about how women are
gonna go to jail this is The Handmaid's
Tale if women seek an abortion then
we're gonna throw them in prison none of
that is true the legislation is
specifically directed at abortion
doctors because this has long been the
pro-life position is that if you want to
cut off abortion at the knees you have
to go after the people who are making
money off the abortions you have to go
after the people who are professionally
performing those abortions in the same
way that a lot of people who aren't sort
of libertarian on drugs say that that
use of drugs should not be treated
harshly by a criminal law but
distribution of drugs is a different
story the same thing is true with regard
to abortion this does include an
exception for cases when the mother's
life is at serious risk but not for
cases of rape or incest the House
approved the measure last month and now
moves to the desk of Governor K IV a
Republican now it makes people very
uncomfortable on the left that
apparently all the people who are behind
this bill more men they're only four
members of the Alabama Senate who are
women and they are all members of the
Democratic Party but they are neglecting
the fact that the governor of Alabama is
a woman KIV and she agrees with her
Republican caucus although the governor
has not publicly committed to signing
the legislation many Republican
lawmakers expect her support in an email
on Tuesday night a spokeswoman for the
governor Lori Davis Chon's
said IV would quote withhold comments
until she has had a chance to thoroughly
review the final version of the bill
that has passed now here's the reality
this bill is not going to go into effect
barring the Supreme Court overruling roe
v wade which is not going to happen I've
been saying for a long time
justice Cavanaugh is not gonna vote for
that Justice Roberts is not gonna vote
for that I have serious doubts whether
the Supreme Court as currently
constituted would vote to overturn roe v
wade should they vote to overturn roe v
wade of course roe v wade is a garbage
case there is no precedent in the
Constitution for the idea that a public
act like the killing of a third party
with the consultation of a doctor
constitutes a quote-unquote right to
privacy a right to privacy that is not
expressed in the Constitution of the
United States
you have a right against unreasonable
search and seizure that is not what this
is you have a variety of rights under
the Bill of Rights one of those rights
is not a generalized quote/unquote right
to privacy and in fact we constantly
violate the quote-unquote right to
privacy in a bevy of circumstances
we violate the right to privacy when it
comes to for example prosecuting people
for for making death threats you know
not death threats that are specifically
directed at at folks via email but if
you put something up on your public
Facebook page or something that is no
less a non private event then going to a
doctor's office and ordering up an
abortion we don't declare a right to
privacy on that there's no right to
privacy when it comes to purchasing a
gun it's not just the question of you
and your gun dealer getting together and
doing it right that there is no
generalized right to privacy in the
Constitution you can't show me it
because it doesn't exist
the reason the right to privacy was
created is because the Supreme Court had
a left-leaning majority this
left-leaning majority decided that that
because of quote-unquote emanations and
penumbra's in the Constitution a
generalized right to privacy was created
that was in Griswold versus Connecticut
where the Supreme Court decided that a
state could not restrict contraceptive
sales to married couples and then it was
extended forward to abortion so this is
this is all just made-up stuff roe v
wade is a very very bad case even if you
are an advocate of the right to abortion
there is nothing in roe v wade that is
legally reasoned roe v wade is a very
poorly reason case even people who are
honest on the left will acknowledge that
it's a poorly recent case and with all
of that said will the supreme court
overrule it no they don't have the
stones to overrule roe v wade they're
gonna leave a row v wade in case in
place because they don't want the
blowback of having overruled a very very
bad case instead what they are likely to
do as I've said before is they're likely
to use the Planned Parenthood versus
Casey undue burden standard and they're
likely to simply gradually allow states
to move closer and closer to conception
or to order to place more conditions on
a woman's ability to get an abortion
based on for example more information
she has to get an ultrasound chest of a
24-hour waiting period that kind of
stuff that's why this is really about
the legal challenge not about whether
this is going to go into effect it's
very unlikely to go into effect
opponents have vowed to challenge the
measure in federal court if it becomes
law even the legislation's supporters
expect that a lower court will block the
measure but it was drafted with exactly
that in mind
correct the bans architects reflecting
the rising conference of abortion
critics nationwide
after the appointment of Brett Kavanaugh
to the Supreme Court hope the justices
will use the case
to reconsider the central holding in row
and allow the Alabama measure to take
effect Eric Johnson who founded the
Alabama pro-life coalition he said until
now there was no prospect of reversing
row he sees himself as a purist on the
abortion issue he said he did not
support a spate of restrictive
legislation that other states have
enacted in recent months including a
so-called fetal heartbeat bills
given the current leanings of the
Supreme Court Johnston said making such
a measure which does not directly
challenged Roe the subject of the courts
made next major abortion case would be a
wasted opportunity
he says heartbeat bills don't challenge
the fundamental conceit at the heart of
roe v wade which is that these are not
human lives he says why not go all the
way and just challenge the central
holding in roe v wade which is that
these are not human lives and let's
overturn that thing well it's not going
to be overturned but it is worthwhile at
least clarifying where the Court stands
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first it is 2019
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds obviously but before you go
dropping hundreds of bucks on a pair you
need to check out wireless earbuds from
Ray Khan
so I have a pair of red Khan earbuds
they are fantastic they're supremely
comfortable.i I was given ear pods for
my birthday by my wife I use the rake
ons instead because they are actually
better and they started about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing the company was actually
co-founded by Ray J celebrities like
brandy and chance myth are already using
ray cons ray cons a 50 wireless earbuds
have totally changed the game for me
they're so comfortable have a bunch of
options you can actually check out they
actually fit in your ear better and
they're really easy to take anywhere
unlike some of the other wireless
options ray con earbuds are both
psilocin discreet no dangling wires no
stems and of course they don't just look
right they also sound fantastic as well
ray con offers their wireless earbuds
for everyone they have a range of colors
at a great price go buy a go to buy rake
on Comm slash Ben to get 20% off your
order
that is buy rake on Comm slash pen you
get 20% off rake on wireless here but if
you and I in a pair now is the time to
get them one more time that's a buy rake
on RA Y Co and buy rake on Comm slash
Ben go check them out right now they're
incredibly comfortable they're cheaper
than a lot of the other options that are
on the market they're cool looking
you're really going to enjoy them if you
like listening to the podcast on your on
your earbuds the best way to get a
wireless pair by ray cons comm slash Ben
and you're getting up to 20% off it's
pretty
so go check them out right now so again
that's by Ray Kahn's calm slash man
can't speak too highly about these these
are these ear pods they really are
spectacular you're really really gonna
they make a great gift they make a
really good gift for anybody for
birthday anniversary go check them out
right now by Raycom slash Bennett okay
senator Roger Smith Herman a Democrat
told his colleagues that during his
wife's pregnancy with their son doctors
had told him it was unlikely the child
would be born alive Smith Herrmann said
that he and his wife had decided to have
the child anyway that his son had been
born with significant health problems
the significance he said is that I had a
choice but that cuts against your
argument in other words your son was
born yes he has significant health
problems it is good that he was born the
law is supposed to protect people with
health problems Democrats and abortion
rights advocates then use the argument
that the measure would drive the
procedure underground endangering the
lives of women and girls well you know
what endanger the lives of babies legal
abortion
I love the argument that the only life
that matters here is the life of the
women or girls in that quality of life
of women and girls you have another
option that is to bear the baby there
there are many people who are willing to
adopt now it's hilarious there are a
bunch of people yesterday when I
defended the pro-life position online so
I don't see you adopting any of these
kids that's true I'm not right now in
the mode of it maybe sometime in the
future my wife and I will adopt but I'm
not adopting right now I have two kids
of my own I also have a generalized rule
I am not in favor of being able to
murder anyone I don't adopt it's a
pretty terrible argument I like in
general I'm not I'm not in favor of you
being able to kill the homeless man down
the street I don't plan on adopting him
and making him my legal ward I don't
think I should be able to stab him in
the face pretty terrible argument and
many of the arguments on the pro side
are insanely terrible really really bad
we'll get to a few more of those
arguments in just a second the Senate
took up the bill again on Tuesday after
an earlier attempt to debate the measure
last week to send it in to shouting in
chaos tensions erupted including some
within the dominant Republican Party
over whether to include exceptions to
the ban in cases of rape and incest a
Senate committee had amended the bill to
include those exceptions prompting a
bitter dispute that that postpone
consideration of the bill for days now
the reason again if you're making a
legal challenge the reason you don't
include rape and incest is because that
allows the supreme court to instead say
that you yourself are not challenging
the central holding of roe v-- wade
which is that unborn human life is not
in fact human life because they can say
okay well in cases of rape and incest
that's also a human life but you're
allowed you're already allowing other
considerations to take hold so if the
purpose is a legal challenge you want
the bill to be as strict as possible
other state measures to restrict
abortion rights have advanced in the
South and Midwest this year inviting
legal fights the governors of Georgia
Kentucky Mississippi and Ohio have
signed fetal heartbeat pills Arkansas
moved up the cutoff point for legal
abortions to 18 weeks of pregnancy from
20 weeks by the way it is insane that it
is considered the quote/unquote
reasonable position for legal abortions
to remain up till 18 weeks of pregnancy
that's crazy I mean you are talking at
that point 18 weeks of pregnancy you are
talking about four and a half months of
pregnancy and abortion is still legal at
that point I mean the fetus is so well
developed at that point it's I mean it's
fully functioning heart fully
functioning and fully functioning blood
stream the brain is already in the in
serious development stages the Alabama
measure goes further in addition to the
potential 99 year sentence for
performing abortions doctors face the
threat of a 10-year term for attempting
to perform one women who receive
abortions would not be prosecuted so do
not believe the propaganda that is being
put out there right now
now the problem with a lot of the
pro-choice advocates the problem for
them is that they continue to make
arguments that are truly truly morally
egregious so Jameela Jamil is an actress
you've seen her on the good place and
she apparently had an abortion and
here's what she tweeted out I had an
abortion when I was young it was the
best decision I have ever made well you
know it'd have been a better decision as
to not get pregnant in the first place
she said it was the best decision I've
ever made ever in all her life her best
decision was killing her own unborn
child both for me and for the baby I
didn't want and wasn't ready for
emotionally psychologically and
financially and so number one she's
acknowledging it is a baby number two
she is saying that it was best for the
baby to die naming a circumstance in
which is best for you to die but just
say let's just forget about everyone
just you generally what's the
circumstance in which it is best for you
to die so you might be able to name some
circumstances let's say that you are in
egregious horrific
and then you say that you want out of
the pain maybe that's an argument let's
say they have a terminal disease maybe
that's an argument but let's say that
you're perfectly healthy human being and
you're and you're or you've been injured
and in a couple months you'll be a
perfectly healthy human being is the
best solution for you to die is it best
for you to die this is a pretty
astonishing statement I can promise you
it was not the best thing for the baby
to die and she says so many children
will end up in foster homes so many
lives ruined so very cruel I promise you
that a child in a foster home would
still prefer to live then simply be
chopped apart in the womb so many lives
ruined you know his life was ruined her
baby who never got to live in the first
place it's a pretty astonishing
statement she says and she says this
isn't any just at all the foster homes
I'm in awe of people who take in
children in need of a family and a home
but if Georgia becomes inundated with
children who are unwanted or unable to
be cared for it will be hard to find
great fostering for them all oh she's
worried about the public burden on
foster homes I see that's obviously that
means we should kill everyone in
countries with lots of very very poor
people where there are lots of street
urchins running around on the streets
the best thing to do probably surround
them up and kill them probably that's
the best thing to do according to
Jameela Jamil that's an amazing
statement but unfortunately that sort of
logic prevails when it comes to the left
and an abortion the logic of the left on
abortion is completely and and
thoroughly unsympathetic to the very
idea that there is a life in the womb
that is biologically incorrect there is
a human life in the womb obviously and
that life does begin at conception there
is no other definition of human life
that makes any sort of logical sense
when people say human life begins with
brain activity okay so if you have
somebody who is in a coma can you kill
them know when they say human life
begins at viability well then my kids
aren't viable now if I left my
three-year-old alone for half a day he
would be dead because he is a crazy
person because all three-year-olds are
crazy people certainly this is true of
newborn babies who cannot support
themselves feed themselves and are
completely dependent on their parents to
take care of them and a lot of old
people who are dependent on caretakers
when people say that the standard should
be sentience and well when you are
asleep you are not sentient does this
mean that
can kill you obviously not when people
say that's different the baby is not
sentient as a state of being yes for a
temporary time and then the baby is when
people try to make a distinction between
oh well it's an embryo or two fetus or
whether it's a baby question is it a
human life or is it not that is the only
category that actually matters here that
is the only category that matters
insofar as the quote-unquote choice to
perform an abortion now what people tend
to do is they will pick hard cases now
the rule in in law is what we used to in
the law school used to describe it as
hard cases make bad law in other words
cases in which you are sympathetic to
one side tend to make for bad general
rules and so what the Left likes to do
is pick hard cases that's why they
picked the rape and the incest cases
that's why they like to pick cases of
tay-sachs babies but hard cases make bad
law in other words the general principle
which is that human life ought to be
protected and that government has a role
in protecting human life is obviously
true one of the things that I found
hilarious yesterday is advocates of
abortion who as a counter-argument to
both the Georgia bill and the Alabama
bill we're saying well now that you're
declaring these these fetuses human life
why don't you force men to pay child
support during pregnancy and the answer
is I'm with you man do it
absolutely you knock up a lady you
shouldn't be able to take off you should
have to pay for that because the fact is
that you created that and you're
responsible for all of that so not only
do I not have a problem with that I am
on the side of that pro-life people have
thought through the consequences of the
of the actions that they are taking
pro-choice people by and large or at
least the pro-choice position by and
large has not actually thought through
the consequences of its own positions it
is just settled for what is convenient
in terms of what they think people
should live like so they think that
abortion is good because it's convenient
they think that in order to facilitate
that convenience we should rule out of
bounds all serious discussions about
what constitutes
human life or at the very least what
they do is they then demagogue the issue
they say things like okay well let's say
the ER in a room with a fertilized
embryo and a five-year-old child and the
room is on fire which one do you save
that's not the question the question is
let's say that you're in a room with an
embryo do you kill it
that is the question right it's not you
have to choose between one life and
another we acknowledge that if the
question is one life is in danger
life happens to be fully born and one
life is not that's why that even the
Alabama law makes an exception for the
life of the mother obviously but that
does not obviate the question as to
whether human life ought to be protected
okay so in the second we're gonna get to
the 2020 race but first there are a lot
of things in life that are not right
carpet and showers for example chunky
style milk ejector seats on helicopters
none of those things are right but
thanks to MIT mobile you don't have to
overpay for wireless anymore with mint
mobile you can cut your wireless bill
down to just 15 bucks a month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online only which means they
can pass significant savings directly to
you
mint mobile makes it easy to cut your
wireless bill down just 15 bucks a month
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan you can keep your old number along
with all your existing contacts with
mint mobile choose between plans with 3
8 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE data stop
paying for unlimited data that you'll
never use every plan comes with
unlimited nationwide talk and text if
you are not 100% satisfied MIT Mobile
has you covered with their 7 day
money-back guarantee ditch your old
wireless bill start saving with mint
mobile to get that new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile comm slash Ben that is mint
mobile comm slash been cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month get free
shipping on your mobile plan at mint
mobile comm slash Ben go check it out
right now again you're going to be
saving tons of money a lot of these
phone companies are charging you
exorbitant fees for supposedly unlimited
data that you are never going to use
instead go to MIT mobile comm slash Ben
and cut your Wireless pull all the way
down to 15 bucks a month and by the way
the coverage is fantastic I mean you're
still going to get reception because the
reception is provided by companies that
provide you your normal reception anyway
go check out mint mobile.com slash Ben
that is mint mobile.com slash Ben go
check it out right now I want to talk
for a second about roe v-- wade and what
the decision actually holds so the
decision itself has been ripped by many
legal scholars including John Hart Eli
who is no right-winger saying that the
decision is quote not constitutional law
and gives almost no sense of an
obligation to try to be John Hart Eli
said quote what is frightening about Roe
is that the super protected right is not
inferable from the language of the
Constitution the framers thinking
respecting the specific problem in issue
any general value driveable from the
positions they included or the nation's
govern
mental structure Lauren's tribe who's
about as left as it gets said quote one
of the most curious things about Roe is
that behind its own verbal smokescreen
the substantive judgment on which it
rests is nowhere to be found now as I
say Planned Parenthood versus Casey is
the court is the case the court is
likely to rely upon when it comes down
to it and while it reaffirmed Rose
holding about viability it abandoned
Rose trimester framework in favor of
fetal viability more generally so Roe
was more specific about about the
standard they said that third trimester
abortions you could theoretically have
restrictions on no none in the second
trimester known in the first trimester
but Planned Parenthood versus Casey
moved to fetal viability the ROE
decision to find viable as potentially
able to live outside the mother's womb
albeit with artificial aid justices in
case he acknowledged viability could
occur at 23 or 24 weeks sometimes even
earlier in light of medical advances the
opinion of the court is a joke the
opinion in Roe is just bad and they just
make it up Harry Blackmun wrote it of
course the Republicans have a wonderful
record of appointing justices Harry
Blackmun real quote but this right of
privacy whether it be founded in the
14th Amendment's concept of personal
liberty and restrictions upon state
action as we feel it is or in the ninth
amendments reservation of Rights to the
people is broad enough to encompass a
woman's decision whether or not to
terminate her pregnancy that's an insane
statement basically this right that
we're creating out of thin air it could
be in the fourteenth amendment could be
in the ninth amendment could be anywhere
man I have no idea but you know we're
just gonna declare it out there and say
that it now covers abortion the court
the court basically spends no time
establishing that a generalized right to
privacy exists the court said that
having unwanted children quote may force
upon the woman a distressful life and
future it's just a piece of leftist
propaganda the court didn't say that
that a right to abortion was absolute it
said that the the other considerations
would include protecting prenatal life
and then they get down to the crux of
the matter they say we need not resolve
the difficult question of when life
begins when those trained in their
respective disciplines of medicine
philosophy and theology are unable to
arrive at any consensus the judiciary
and this point of the development of
man's knowledge is not in a position to
speculate as to the answer okay that of
course is absolute sheer nonsense
virtually everyone
in medicine philosophy and theology has
declared that life begins at conception
because it does biologically speaking an
independent human life begins at
conception there is no other point that
you can declare that life begins the
court in Roe settled on three trimesters
of pregnancy as the framework they said
that the court that there could be no
restrictions on a woman's ability during
the first trimester after the first
trimester the court ruled that evidence
of increasing risks to mother's health
gave the state a compelling interest and
it could enact medical regulation so
long as they were reasonable and
narrowly tailored and then at the
beginning of the third trimester they
said that there could be effectively
that there could effectively be
prohibitions on abortion where necessary
to protect mother's life or health the
then you could have an abortion that was
that was basically the way that that
worked and then Planned Parenthood
versus Casey significantly sort of
limited that it's a it's a bad ruling in
and of itself Planned Parenthood versus
Casey and they crafted as I say the
undue burden standard for abortion
restriction restrictions under Roe the
state could not regulate abortions in
the first trimester theoretically under
Planned Parenthood versus Casey they
could so as I have said the likely
outcome of all of this is that the court
broadens the standard under Planned
Parenthood versus Casey but does not
overrule roe v wade even though roe v
wade as i have said is a garbage case
that has virtually no support in the
comment when I say virtually no I mean
none no support in the Constitution
whatsoever Sandra Day O'Connor wrote the
opinion in Planned Parenthood versus
Casey and it is not a good opinion it is
a very not good opinion nonetheless it
will continue to be the standard simply
because the Supreme Court is a group of
people who basically decide to make
politics or make politics dominate the
law the law is less important than
politics and thus the court has
continuously acted as a political body
not as a legal body unfortunately in
violation of the prescriptions of the
Federalist Papers in which Alexander
Hamilton argued that if ever the court
should simply be using its will as
opposed to the interpretation of the law
it would lose its raise on debt it would
there would be no reason for it to exist
okay meanwhile the 2020 race is finally
starting to get interesting and it's
getting interesting because of the
inimitable aoc man she is really going
after it so AOC does not want Joe Biden
she represents the the quote-unquote
justice Democrat wing of the party
the radical wing of the Democratic Party
the wing of the party that Nancy Pelosi
has derided is having about three people
but she does get all the publicity she
was going after Joe Biden she's
apparently deciding between Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders right now if
she endorses Elizabeth Warren that could
in fact be a death knell for Bernie
Sanders is lagging campaign yesterday
however her chief focus was going after
Joe Biden who she certainly doesn't want
as the nominee because he's
quote-unquote to moderate here she is
slamming Biden over his supposed
middle-of-the-road stance with regard to
climate change if the same politicians
who refuse to act then are gonna try to
come back today and say we need a middle
of the middle-of-the-road
approach to save our lives that is too
much for me we cannot we cannot and we
will not accept anything less than a
solution to save ourselves and that's
exactly what this is okay so that is a
slap at Joe Biden Joe Biden responded by
saying no no no no no she's not slapping
at me everyone took it as a slap at Joe
Biden because it basically was I mean
Joe Biden himself was booed when he was
mentioned as having supposedly said that
he had a middle-of-the-road stand on
climate change now he says I'm not
middle-of-the-road guys because I'm far
less like just just love me love me you
know
the statement that I made and look at my
record she'll find that nobody has been
more consistent about taking it on the
environment and a great revolution than
I have and so he doesn't think she was
talking about him
uh yeah Joe she was talking about you
and if you think you're gonna escape so
easily I mean he sounds old there he
really does and it's a problem for him
because the new vibrant wave of youthful
Democrats they've got all the passion
and all the all the moves and their hip
and they can dance there they're really
not going to accept the John with cow
figure that is Joe Biden when it comes
to their their a full push for socialism
okay in a second we're gonna get two
more from the 2020 race in the dilemma
of Joe Biden but first folks you need to
make sure that you tune in tomorrow at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific for our
latest episode of the conversation the
execrable michael moles will be
answering your questions live on air so
make them good as always Alicia we'll be
there to keep knowles in line the
episode will be free for everyone to
watch on Facebook and YouTube only
subscribers can ask the questions so
subscribe to get your questions answered
by Michael Knowles tomorrow at 4 p.m.
Eastern 7:00 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation my first question why do
you have a job I'm really hoping that
Michael moles answers that one properly
and that if he does not then we get rid
of him but I suppose that you can ask
him any question you choose I just think
it'd be hilarious if every question you
asked was that so if I'm not saying you
should I'm just saying you totally
should do that okay also you should come
subscribe for a variety of reasons
write your subscribership helps us bring
the show to you every day and helps pay
our staff it helps make sure that we are
insulated from the jackasses over places
like media matters your subscribership
makes sure that we can continue to bring
you great content even if social media
giants decide to crack down on
conservatives that's what your
subscribership does we always appreciate
its $9.99 a month and for that yet all
sorts of goodies including two
additional hours of me live on video
every single day we are working hard for
your money also you get the annual
subscription for 99 dollars you get this
the leftist Cheers hut or cold tumbler
now notice it does not say I get a lot
of questions about this particular
vessel
it says leftist tears not liberal tears
right liberals you know you don't have
to make liberals cry they're nice people
who just disagree with you on politics
leftist here's you know people who
actually want to restrict people from
speaking people whose idea is do too
lock Andrew Klavan from speaking at a
university by locking the doors which is
what happened last night and one of
these universities those tears we
treasure and we hold them and we store
them in this vessel the leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr go check it out right
now for $99 a year you can get the
leftist here as hot or cold a tumblr
it's cheaper than the monthly
subscription anyway also you get extra
access to our Sunday special it comes
out on Saturday instead you get extra
questions behind the paywall all sorts
of goodies I'm starting a new project
today without the permission of or or go
ahead of my business partner I'm just
starting it because man I'm gonna board
I'll be honest with you this is this
news cycle is a little slow so I'm just
gonna start something and I think it
will be available mostly for subscribers
I'm not gonna tell you about it now
suffice it to say it should be kind of
awesome so go check us out right now
subscribe leave us a review over at
YouTube or iTunes where our listenership
is extraordinary we are the second most
listen to podcast in America by
statistics last month let's make it
number one this month go leave us a
review we always appreciate it we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so when Joe Biden again he is
trying to escape the ramifications of
the fact that he is moderate enough to
win a general election but to moderate
for the the excited wing of his base and
that doesn't make a difference right if
your base is not super excited about you
if they are mostly motivated by how much
they don't like the other guy they
better I hate that guy with a rampant
passion and they must they better feel
like it's an emergency like if the
economy is good and if things are
generally okay in their lives and they
just don't really like Trump very much
I'm not sure that that is enough to get
them over the hump that means that you
have to have one of two things either
broad public appeal or a very very
excited base right Donald Trump barely
got over the hump against a candidate
the Republicans loathe Hillary Clinton
because there was a segment of the base
that was super excited about Donald
Trump hey I'm not sure who in the
Democratic base is super excited about
Joe Biden they hope that he has brought
appeal the problem is that he may have
to choose between the broad appeal and
the very excited base you know the
people who are gonna go knock on doors
the people who are going to spend their
days phone-banking
are those people gonna do that for Joe
Biden it's a serious question and aoc
Bernie Sanders they're ripping on Joe
Biden about this here's Bernie Sanders
and of subtweeting Joe Biden on climate
change when you're dealing with the
future of the planet and making sure
that our kids and our grandchildren have
a healthy and habitable world in which
to live I don't know how you go too far
I mean this is an existential threat not
just to the United States but to the
entire planet we have a moral obligation
to combat climate change to bring the
entire world together this is not an
American issue this is a global issue to
bring the world together to transform
our energy system away from fossil fuel
to energy efficiency and sustainable
energies and to me we don't have a
choice we don't have a choice we have to
knock Joe Biden it's the only way so
this is Bernie Sanders's pitch and also
it's Bernie Sanders who's pushing
medicare-for-all a proposal so popular
with the Democratic base that all of the
fence sitters like Kamala Harris have
come down in favor of it at least when
they're not against it Joe Biden however
has said that he does not support
turning Medicare into a national health
insurance program for everyone because
quote the vast majority of people are
satisfied with their own health care
system today
he said he favors making a Medicare
option available to all people in which
he'd be able to keep your own insurance
if you are satisfied so he's in favor
of a quote-unquote public option but the
problem with the quote-unquote public
option is that if people are opting into
Medicare and doctors are not taking
Medicare well then you're not going to
be getting very good care through
Medicare it's one of the reasons why
people like Joe like people people like
Bernie Sanders who are Medicare for all
proponents have said we need to
eliminate private health insurance as an
option because too many healthy people
are going to be buying private health
insurance and that means that Medicare
for all is going to be incredibly
expensive basically the only people who
are going to get Medicare for all or
Medicare for a public option are gonna
be high-risk people so the government
absorbs the cost for all the high-risk
people the reimbursement rates are too
low those people still can't get care
from the doctors that they want so we
have to force everyone into one giant
pool via Medicare for all the question
in health insurance is always risk pools
and the problem is that if you if you
bifurcate the risk pools into healthy
people and non healthy people and the
non healthy people end up on the
government dole and the healthy people
all end up getting private health
insurance then the government ends up
footing an enormous enormous burden in
order to get those people health care in
the first place so that is why the Joe
Biden plan has largely been opposed by
Democrats on the other hand it's been
opposed by Republicans the public option
because there is the looming risk that
public option quickly turns into
Medicare for all because the government
can also subsidize at a rate that no one
else can so you could see a world where
the government starts subsidizing
Medicare for the public option and
everybody simply dumps their private
health insurance employers start dumping
private health insurance and tossing
people on to the Medicare rolls and
private insurance industry dies and then
doctors are basically roped into de
facto Medicare for all so Joe Biden has
picked the least popular option the
public option option is actually the
least popular option there's Medicare
for all hardcore Bernie i'ts love that
and then there's private health
insurance without a public option and
Republicans are generally in favor of
that and then there is the public option
option which is so unpopular that Barack
Obama couldn't even get a public option
through his own party already controlled
the Senate and the house he could not
get a public option through his own
party that is Joe Biden's position
because he's quote-unquote moderate now
the way he's trying to make up for the
fact that he is quote unquote moderate
is by suggesting and by the way his
moderation
forgets that his moderation extends to
his prior record so he was confronted
about his crime bill yesterday now he's
been trying to make amends for his 1994
support for the crime belt I don't think
you should have to make amends for a
crime bill that helped lower the crime
rate dramatically and when people say
well it led to mass incarceration right
it locked up more criminals you're gonna
have to show me all the innocent people
who went to jail because of the 1994
crime bill when people say that it was
racially biased the 94 crime bill you're
gonna have to show me how you can't just
show me the disproportionate number of
minorities in prison you're going to
have to show me that they were
wrongfully arrested wrongfully
prosecuted and wrongfully convicted he
has nothing to apologize for in my view
the 1994 crime bill and he's been trying
to apologize for it nonetheless he has
to apologize because the woke base has
suggested that the ninety-four crime
bill was a great evil even though in
1994 the crime rates in the United
States were out of control
inner-city politicians were supporting
the crime bill Joe Biden says that but
that ain't gonna be popular with a vast
majority of his own base really brown
communities that have been ravaged by
the war on drugs and mass incarceration
folks let's get some straight 9200 100
prisoners in a behind the bars are in a
state prison not a federal prison this
idea that the crime bill generated mass
incarceration it did not generate mass
incarceration what happened is the mass
incarceration incurred by the states
setting mandatory sentences what
happened was if you go back and look the
Black Caucus supported the bill so folks
we don't need any more mandatory
sentences period okay what's hilarious
about that that we don't need any
mandatory sentences is that very often
mandatory sentences were better for a
lot of the people convicted because they
evened the playing field the problem is
without mandatory minimums or without
mandatory maximums what you end up with
his judge is basically deciding so if
you want to remove bias from the system
mandatory minimums are actually in even
a more even way of doing all of this but
again the real problem for Joe Biden
here is who is he is he quote-unquote
moderate Joe from the past or is he
progressive Joe for the future this is
why Joe Biden is trying to bridge that
gap with simple Trump hatred he's trying
to paste over this particular gap he's
trying to spackle over
that that gap in the wall by talking
about how Trump is an illegitimate
president he was confronted yesterday by
a woman who who started talking about
how Trump was was installed by the
Russians and Joe Biden did something
truly terrible here he is he's
legitimate and my biggest fear is that
he's gonna do it again with the help of
lad his best pal and we're gonna be
stuck for six more years of this guy and
that is terrifying
it's terrible would you be my vice
president some folks look you're
absolutely right and now they have an
investigation of the investigators who
are investigating whether or not
Vladimir Putin and the Russians engaged
in trying to affect our life give me a
break
gosh almighty okay that is an
astonishing statement by Joe Biden it's
so funny Joe Biden said that he used to
be you know he's very close with John
McCain and there were good buddies and
he's to hang out I'm old enough to
remember that in 2008 John McCain was at
a rally and somebody got up at the rally
and said that Barack Obama was a Muslim
and John McCain shut him down
he said no Barack Obama is not a Muslim
and you have no evidence that he is a
Muslim and you shouldn't try to hit him
with charges that are untrue and the
media gave him virtually no credit at
the time they they suggested that John
McCain was still crazy old codger and
then they backed Barack Obama despite
the fact that John McCain did that only
later did they come around say what a
decent man that John McCain was remember
that John McCain who stood up to his own
party when somebody said that well what
that lady said there is flatly untrue
Donald Trump did not win because the
Russians were working with Donald Trump
to put him in the White House he is not
an illegitimate president and yet you're
not hearing Joe Biden shut it down it's
one of my pet peeves with a lot of folks
on the left when it comes to the import
the the placing of standards they're all
too eager to insist that Republicans
play standards and then when it's their
turn to actually uphold the standard
against their own supporters they won't
do it they are nowhere to be found they
run for the hills I've mentioned before
that there's this tendency on the left
to suggest that they want to play by the
Marquess of Queensberry rules and then
when it comes down to it those rules go
completely out the window you can see
that during the last election cycle when
it was Donald Trump is an evil evil evil
man for using WikiLeaks material well
Hillary Clinton was actively soliciting
material from Ukraine to use against
Paul Manafort and Donald Trump as
courted by Politico virtually no big
media coverage there was none in 2016
and the media coverage even in 2017 when
this came out was incredibly muted
there's there's a reason that
Republicans finally got tired and said
listen Donald Trump doesn't play by the
rules because you guys don't play by the
rules there is there's a great
temptation in politics to abandon the
rules if you feel that your opponents is
not playing by them and Democrats have
repeatedly refused to play by the rules
it's it's it's what this is in fact how
you got Trump this is in fact how you
got from you get John McCain who calls
out a lie about his political opponent
during the presidential race and his
castigated is a racist sexist pig and
homophobe anyway and then you have Joe
Biden who refuses to stand up to a
random crowd member who says the Donald
Trump is an illegitimate president and
it's not just Joe Biden you got beta
O'Rourke praising Stacey Abrams for
refusing to accept the results of
election so bado trying to pander to his
base wouldn't it be better if peyto said
listen Stacey Abrams is a great
candidate and she lost her race instead
he's on the view yesterday and he says
Stacey Abrams she's brilliant ways what
in the world is he talking about she has
spent the last several months on the
campaign trail proclaiming that she was
job out of the governorship of Georgia
even though she lost by 55,000 votes and
there is no math by which she won here
is beta O'Rourke actively working to
undermine faith in electoral
institutions about five minutes after
Democrat said that Trump was going to do
it and was gonna be super bad Stacey
Abrams who is a real hero to me
the grace with which she met that defeat
on an unfair unlevel playing field with
the Secretary of State perhaps rigging
in in part that election her focus on
democracy form a new Voting Rights Act
ensuring that every single vote counts
in this country is inspiring stuff at a
time that our democracy is so badly
broken okay this is just like what in
the world well what then none of that
not a word of that is true I mean I
understand that that bado is desperately
trying to get back in this race
eventually he'd like to be able to to
buy more than one shirt I think but he
is but but that's crazy talk when when
what are the Democrats ever gonna have a
sister souljah moment a sister souljah
moment was named after a Democrat Bill
Clinton was talk
about a woman in sister souljah who had
said something racially-charged and he
came back at her and said that is not
true
Democrats haven't had one of those in a
very very long time instead they have
loud capture of their own base by
radicals now another example Democrats
have been claiming that Donald Trump is
inciting violence against the press then
what he does is he attacks members of
the press in order to deal egde it
amazed the press and this is a threat to
the First Amendment this is a threat to
our institutions Jim Acosta is reading a
whole book about it guys he's reading
his audiobook in an air-conditioned
studio about the great threat to the
American press from Donald Trump at the
same time that Venezuela is throwing CNN
reporters out of the country well now
Elizabeth Warren is tweeting out about
how Fox News is not really media how
they are a quote unquote hate for-profit
racket that gives a megaphone to racists
and conspiracists it's designed to turn
us against each other
risking life and death consequences to
provide cover for the corruption that's
rotting our government and hollowing out
our middle class in other words you
might say according to Elizabeth Warren
that Fox News is fake news that's what
you might say if you were Elizabeth
Warren
she says hate for profit only works if
there's profit so Fox News balance is a
mix of bigotry racism and outright lies
with enough legit journalism to make the
claim to advertisers that it's a
reputable news outlet it's all about
dragging in ad money big ad money so in
other words they're a corrupt evil
organization that effectively ought to
be shut down is what Elizabeth Warren is
contending and then she posted this
video with pictures of of Sean Hannity
and Tucker Carlson it's actually just a
gif of Sean Hannity Tucker Carlson Laura
Ingraham judge Jeanine in in red in the
background as a stop the hate for-profit
fox news racket I mean this is straight
from the media macit Media Matters
playbook now does this constitute
incitement does this constitute an
attack on the press does this constitute
an attack on the First Amendment
she couldn't say whatever she wants I
don't really care I don't care that
President Trump has attacked what he
believes to be members of the press were
unfair I care what he miss labels them
such I camera he miss labels them such
and I care what Elizabeth Warren says
that Fox News is a hate for-profit
racket and that people like Bret Baier
are apparently just being used as
floozies by the Fox News brand in order
to legitimize the brand I mean on a
business level this isn't even true it's
not true the
is that advertisers want to advertise on
all the shows Elizabeth Warren hates
because they get good ratings Fox and
Bret bear doesn't exist attitude to rip
on Bret bear or Dana Perino or Martha
McCallum or shannon bream by suggesting
that they're just fronts for Sean like
they're not independent human beings
it's pretty perverse but Elizabeth
Warren does it all the time the the
20/20 Democrats are demonstrating full
scale that all of the rules they say
that Donald Trump broke they've been
saying that Donald Trump broke American
politics this proves my statement Donald
Trump did not break American politics
American politics was broken long before
Donald Trump Trump is a symptom of that
broken politics he's a response to that
broken politics he is not in and of
himself the breaking force that doesn't
mean he's made our broken politics
better it does mean that if you're
blaming Donald Trump for divisions in
America you have a memory span of a flea
and you are blinding yourself actively
to the Democratic Party right now and
how they are doing all the things they
accuse president Trump of doing in a on
a regular basis already so let's do some
things I like and then let's do some
things that I hate so things that I like
today so yesterday I did John wick one
now I'm gonna get to the John wick movie
that is better I know this is a
controversial opinion John wick too is
better it is more amusing it is more
interesting it's more comic book II
basically John wick one is a
straightforward revenge drama in which
about half half an hour in it turns from
a straightforward revenge drama into
sort of comic book II stuff when he gets
to the Continental Hotel and the
Continental Hotel is this hotel for
assassins all that is the most fun part
of John wick John wick too is entirely
that so the entire thing is the
Continental Hotel and assassins trying
to kill other assassins and it's just
great here's a little bit of the trailer
welcome to Rome is this a formal event
or a social affair social how many
buttons two and what style
tactical mr. wick do enjoy your Posse
so I manage on with binge right now
because of course John wick three comes
out this weekend which is the only thing
that truly matters I've gotten my wife
into the John wick movies now and she is
one thing I love about my wife but when
you're married for a while we're more
married 11 years in July when you're
married for a while one of the most fun
things about your spouse is when they
randomly surprise you and my wife is the
kind of person who likes to watch chick
flicks like real chick flicks she's the
kind of person who doesn't really like
violence in movies or anything she
really likes the John wick movies and
it's really charming like the fact that
she thinks that these are really fun and
hilarious is pretty great and the truth
is she likes real I like she she loves
die hard which is hysterical a lot of
the folks in the offices met my wife so
they know how funny this is I think my
wife is is unlike me one of the nicest
people on planet earth and so the fact
that she loves John wick is just great
there's a dark side of my wife that I
really enjoy all right time for a couple
of things that that I hate all righty so
one of the one of the stupidest things
in American politics that happened over
the last couple of years is there was a
restaurant called the red hen in
Lexington Virginia and that restaurant
through Sarah Huckabee stands out so
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the press
secretary for the President of the
United States sat down for a meal and
they said you are not welcome here now I
have long been an advocate if you do not
want to have somebody at your restaurant
you should not be forced to have
somebody at your restaurant I think it's
an idiotic aspect of the Civil Rights
Act and the private establishments are
told what they can and cannot do Jim
Crow laws were designed to tell private
establishments what they could or could
not do people tend to forget it wasn't
an informal regime alone of Jim Crow in
the south it was a very formal regime
that prevented restaurants from for
example having desegregated seating in
places like Mississippi and Alabama and
if you violated that then the government
would find you they would come in and
they would harm you the Civil Rights Act
and a lot of wonderful things one of the
things I think that was not so wonderful
is it conflated public with private and
suggested that the federal government
has the authority to tell private
business owners how to conduct their
business if they were quote-unquote
public accommodations now we are seeing
the public
rulz expands it out to include virtually
every area of human activities that the
government can regulate it that's what
we're seeing in the so called the
quality act being pushed by Democrats
well I think you should be able to have
whoever you want not eat at your
restaurant or eat at a restaurant and
that includes people I disagree with
like Stephanie Wilkinson so Stephanie
will considered something that I
disagree with and I think it's quite
horrible she said that that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders cannot eat at her
restaurant I think that's wrong if I
owned a restaurant I would certainly
allow Democrats to eat at my restaurant
I was certainly allowed Jay Carney or
Robert Gibbs to come in and have a meal
I wouldn't have any problem with that
and I find it silly that anybody would
have a problem with that just the same
as I would find it silly if a gay couple
came into my restaurant and sat down to
eat I wouldn't be like get out now as a
religious person it's a different thing
if you are asking me to participate in a
same-sex wedding but you just want to
come in and eat just like anybody else
wouldn't want to come in and eat I have
no problem with that but Sarah Stephanie
Wilkinson is being praised by the
Washington Post for a decision that if
she had made it against either a
Democrat or against a person of any
other group would be considered insane
instead they run this puff piece by
Stephanie Wilkinson called I own the red
hen restaurant that as Sarah Hass
Sanders to leave resistance is in futile
so in other words everybody should do
this we should divide the country along
political lines by pursuing all of this
now as I say I think she has the right
to do this I think that she should do it
if she wants to and I think other people
should stop eating at the red head and
if people want to support the red hen
because of this they could do that too
it's a free country that is fine with me
but the fact that the Washington Post is
printing this piece and the fact that
the Washington Post has taken repeatedly
the editorial position that if you are
Jack Phillips and you own a cake shop
and you don't want to cater a same-sex
wedding that you are an emissary of evil
and intolerance in the United States is
wildly inconsistent and demonstrates
once again and when it comes to the left
the double standard is simple if it is
good for the left they are for it if it
is bad for the left they are against it
there is no other standard there is no
objective standard of law that applies
equally to everyone there's no objective
standard of morality that applies
equally to everyone if you aren't on the
hard left or apparently on the editorial
board over at the Washington Post okay
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content or we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
the state of Alabama passes the most
restrictive abortion law in the country
we examine the legal and political
ramifications and ask the question on
everybody's mind will we live to see the
overturning of roe v wade check it out
on the Michael Noel's show